here's a question from complex numbers
let alpha beta and gamma be the distinct
roots of the cubic equation and then
they provide you this equation so let's
start by writing that cubic down X cubed
plus ax squared plus BX minus 54 equals
0
they tell us they've got alpha beta and
gamma the distinct roots alpha beta
gamma the distinct roots that means
they're just not equal to each other
they're separate or distinct a and B
these two coefficients here are real
numbers so I'll write that down and be
real and then you get these two
equations which relate all of the roots
to each other alpha beta and gamma so
I've got alpha squared plus beta squared
equals 0 and alpha squared plus speed
sorry that's a gamma squared is equal to
zero all right so now I have to start
thinking about all these different
letters ships here part one explain why
beta plus gamma equals zero so required
to prove that beta plus gamma equals
zero now the first place I go to think
about this is these two equations in
here alpha squared plus beta squared
equals 0 and alpha square plus gamma
squared equals zero I can see there's a
clear relationship between them there's
so much in common
so I'll call one equation one call the
other equation two so how should I put
these together to get a relationship
between just beta and gamma
without the alpha squared in the way and
the answer is well if I subtract these
two equations from each other
that'll eliminate the outer square all
that'll leave me with is meters squared
whereas gamma squared and because this
is difference of squares
I can factorize that like so
okay so now if I solve for better I've
got two solutions from this factor I've
got better equals gamma and from this
solution I've got beta equals negative
gamma but immediately you can see an
issue namely that because we said right
at the outset that alpha beta and gamma
are distinct they're not equal therefore
I can take be a conical gamma they can't
be the same root so I can reject this
solution so beta equals negative gamma
only and if I move that gamma over to
the other side and I've got beat up plus
gamma equals zero as required okay so
far so good now let's have a look at
part 2 part 2 says explain why alpha the
other root that we haven't talked about
yet explain why alpha is real so part 2
I am required to prove that how far is
real so how do I go about this well I
now can think about using this this what
I've just used what I've just proven
here this result I'm gonna use that
because the question has this important
word hence it says hence explain why
alpha is real so I'm going to use part 1
so when I look at what I've just proven
beta post gamma equals zero this clearly
has to do with some of roots when you've
got a polynomial here in terms of all of
its coefficients you can get the
relationships between the roots using
vieta's results so if you can trim what
those look like for instance the one
that relates to this one the sum of the
roots one at a time alpha plus beta plus
gamma would be equal to minus a that's
this coefficient here on one well that's
just right okay but but beta plus gamma
that's equal to zero right so alpha plus
zero equals negative a so therefore
alpha on its own and that's negative a
and since since out a we said at the
beginning that coefficient there is real
since a is real then negative a will
also be real so there we go alpha must
be real okay
sit in let's move on part 3 says hence
or otherwise explain why beta and gamma
these two roots up here are complex and
purely imaginary okay so where are we
going to go to look at this I know that
alpha is real and B'Etor and gamma are
related in this way beta plus gamma
equals zero so I'm gonna use the phone
I'm going to go back to this first
equation here and then we're going to
say look I've I've got this relationship
and I also know some things about alpha
now is equal to negative 8 so let's put
those two together I'm going to
substitute one into the other so I'll
say since this is part 3 since alpha
equals negative a I'll substitute into
that first equation which I caught one
okay so that means that I mean alpha
squared plus beta squared equals zero is
what was given to us but I know that
alpha is negative a so I've got this
okay the the double negative here will
cancel so I've got a squared plus beta
squared equals zero don't confuse your a
with an alpha okay so if I try and solve
for beta right now I've got negative a
squared on this side right which means
that beta must be now because this is a
negative number that's where you're
going to get the imaginary stuff from
right so I'm going to get plus or minus
a alright right which means that
whichever of these values it takes that
means that beta is purely imaginary
there's no real part to this there's no
you know a plus bi sort of thing this is
just imaginary so there you go
beta is purely imaginary now because I
know that beta is equal to negative
gamma right that means that
we'll be rather than plus or minus AI
it'll be minus plus AI because if bid is
positive AI then GABA will be negative
and vice versa okay
so therefore and this is from from part
one therefore because again GABA has no
real part to it
gamma is also purely imaginary okay so
that's really good
I've got knocked down three parts out of
four let's have a look at this last part
part four find a and B find out what
these coefficients of the original
equation are okay so where are we going
to go for this I've already used the the
sum of the roots here these alpha plus
beta plus gamma but because I know all
these things are how alpha beta and
gamma relate I'm gonna now use my
product of roots are three at a time
that's alpha beta gamma and that's going
to be if this is the summer fruits one
at a time
is is negative a on one and then two at
a time would be B on one and so three at
a time that's the product of the roots
would be negative negative 54 so that's
just going to be 54 so I've got this
okay
that's the product of roots so how am I
gonna use this well I know tons of stuff
about alpha beta and gamma and how they
relate for instance I know that alpha is
negative 8 I've got beter in there and I
also know that gamma is negative beta
right so that's 54 okay well hold on a
second I also know that what I've got
here is these negatives a together
cancel so I've got an an a at the front
and a beta squared here which is also
equal to 54 but hold on a second I had a
beta squared up here I'll just call this
because I got this from Equation 1 I'll
call this point in the working one a so
I can say since B squared equals
negative a squared
equation one a I can say that this is
going to be a times negative a squared
it's 54 okay so wait hold on a second
I've got negative a cubed equals 54 so a
cubed equals negative 54 like so so a is
equal to negative 54 to the power of 1/3
or the cube root of 54 if you like it
that way so that's really good I've got
the value of a so now how do I work out
the value of B how do I use this
well I used the summer fruits one at a
time here I've used their product of
roots or the summer fruits at three at a
time the last summer product of roots or
last vieta's results that I haven't used
is the sum of the roots two at a time so
that is alpha beta plus beta gamma plus
alpha gamma that's all of the pairs that
you can make and if I go back to my
original it's going to be B on one
that's just equal to B okay but in here
I could substitute a whole bunch of
things I mean I do an alpha yeah I
already know that's minus a you got a
beater there and I've got B 2 times
negative beat up because that's let's
just gather there and then I've got a
negative a again and a negative beat up
again that's all equal to B okay this is
really good because I can see that these
terms and these terms are exactly going
to cancel that's a plus a B dot and
that's a minus a beta so all I'm gonna
be left with is a B 2 squared or a
negative B 2 squared on this side and if
B this sign so what I've got is this are
negative B 2 squared I can take that in
big negative over there and I already
know from Equation 1 a which I noted
here that B 2 squared equals negative a
squared so that's negative a squared in
there okay cool so rearranging cuz I I
know what a is I want to solve for B
I've got B equals aids
square and that means it's 54 ^ 1/3 or I
should say negative 54 the power foot
square that's 54 to the power of 2/3
will you use your index laws now I'll
admit that looks bit awkward 54 negative
54 the power of third that's my a value
negative 50 4 to the power 3rd and 54 to
the power of 2/3 that's my B value but
if you slip them back into the original
equation just to confirm things you
don't have to do this but just to settle
it for yourself you can see that back in
the original equation it will look like
this X cubed minus 54 2/3 x squared plus
54 that 1/2 2/3 X minus that 54 CH we
had in the original now this is really
easy to factorize because of the numbers
that we've chosen right for instance
here I take out a factor of x squared
and that gives you X most 54 to 1/3 okay
over here I'll take out a factor of 50
for the power of 2/3
now here that's obviously just going to
give you X when you divide 54 by 54.5
two-thirds your index laws tell you
that'll be 54 the power of 1/3 okay so
now I've got this common factor X minus
the cube root of 54 and then the other
guys you've got neck squared plus 54 to
the power of 2/3 okay now because this
is complex numbers we can actually
factorize further because here this is
difference of squares if you include and
I squared in there all right so you got
X minus 54 third x squared minus 54 to
the power of 2/3 I squared that I
squared will be a negative 1 will cancel
with that which gives you back the
original so now that it looks like
difference of squares properly I can
factorize it which gives me this 54 to
the power of 1/3 X minus 54 to the power
of 1/3 I that's the square root of this
and X plus 54 to a third eye so these
are these these obviously they're all
the cube root of 50
for in case you don't let that index
notation okay which means that X is
equal to here my solutions 54 to power
third is what I get from this factor or
what I get from these two factors is its
fossil - 54 to the power of 1/3 I and
this satisfies all our original things
this thing here right is alpha these two
solutions here are beta and gamma
they're purely imaginary
all three roots are distinct so we've
satisfied the original question